all right math
math oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from la
crescenta california it's
at the top of the two freeway go to a
suburb of l.a
yeah it's what's called a census
designated place
they found out that there was a place
there when they did the census
it's not part of a town or city it's
part of the county unincorporated
but they didn't notice it until they did
the census i read this on wikipedia
and how was your childhood yeah both
your parents as a kid
uh i i don't like the people who raised
me
either one of them and i recently
learned that i was adopted and so that
they're so they're not my parents
and um i had a kind of miserable time
but it was a while ago
i kind of visual time it was a while ago
oh yeah how would you describe your
childhood
i mean was there abuse or anything like
that um
it was really boring
i wasn't allowed to
go out enough have enough friends i
spent my whole uh all my free time
doing homework and
basically doing homework and sometimes
watching tv
they were very uh
against me uh going out with uh other
kids my age
and partying or whatever against drugs
very against um like
dating very against
driving
so i don't know it sucked but
so you went on your own at what age oh i
lived there until i was
i lived here until i went to college and
i went to college when i was
17. i went to university of southern
california you went to usc
good for you so you're a good student
yeah i was a good student and
you went on your own after school went
on my own after school
what uh what what did you do after you
graduated
after i graduated then i got um a
master's
in in new york and then i
what did i do after i learned to dance
finally i saw i stopped talking to them
like uh like the people that raised me i
uh learned to do drugs
learn to dance uh learn to
date sort of um had a long relationship
with a boy
and with a guy
his name is stephen oh yeah we had a
band together it's called belt
and guys are your preference guys my
preference
um i'm into do you know who david
griffith is i'm really into him
he's in driving miss daisy i think he
calls himself
a man not a guy
or maybe what does he call himself
an actor an old
oh yeah and a really old drunk guy okay
goes to the guy never mind
yeah guys are my preference i don't um
i'm not into girls sexually but i
like girls of course and you you are
born a female
yeah yeah um so you've worked you had
jobs
oh yeah i've had jobs um i was a uh
a host at a sushi and shabu-shabu
restaurant
i was a editor
of other people's graduate school
admissions essays
i was a
retail employee at american apparel okay
and i was
a person who let you in
front desk person at a bath house in san
francisco called
eros and so drugs come into your life at
what age
george came into my life um at what age
i think i was pretty young the first
time i
had a drug but i didn't start to do
drugs until i was
like in college basically and i wish i
had been able to do
more of them earlier but the people who
raised me the
like my mom and dad and also my sister
are all uh very
um
like scared of drugs although they do
them kind of
like like yeah kind of not really but
kind of
meet me i love drugs what is your drug
my favorites are um
methamphetamine uh cannabis marijuana
and lsd i also really love mda and mdma
and how do you support yourself now
film i think disney the studio
is going to help me make a feature film
other things i know how to do
are be a cashier and
be the singer in a band and
go to the uh ebt office
and you so where are you staying now
right now i'm staying
i'm not sure of the address actually but
you're on the street
have been for having for almost two
years three years yeah
and how has that experience has that
been for you
oh i mean
shitty of course um boring mostly
uh i've had a lot of trouble accessing
accurate information about like like
basic things involving housing
which uh like a housing office that
isn't closed
captioning not
who was available either trained wrong
or unethical or whatever
that's part of the part of the reason i
have that problem is like i'm in like
the wrong like tradition of it i mean
like the misinformation tradition of it
and uh also uh i've noticed that i
i've noticed this is a huge problem for
many people in america like
like uh accessing information about
housing
i'm sure you've noticed a lot of people
do intense and probably don't want you
sorry i know that's boring that's all
right so you you still have contact with
your family
or no well um i don't consider my family
the people that raise me
and i don't want to be in touch with him
and mostly i'm not
um they recently one of them recently um
filed a missing persons report about me
and i think i was able to address it and
let them know that i'm alive and
and that i don't have to talk to them
nobody has to like anybody etc how old
are you now
i'm 40. i turned 40 in june you're 40.
have you been in love before yeah i've
been in love before yeah
[Music]
have you i have yeah
great experience yeah until it's not
great
great experience since it's not yeah um
but that you had you've had good
relationships
[Music]
um good relationships
since i've been homeless i haven't had a
phone or laptop in almost two years to
uh
express myself to people sort of
although you know of course there's
always talking
um i feel sort of
i'm like oh i want to check and like
make sure
my conversations are good but i think so
like i think i think i've had some like
really really good and deep
relationships not necessarily that i
even liked all of those people but
like do you have friends yeah um
i have friends i need to meet more of
them in person but uh
but i've done this type of thing before
like find someone really cool on
facebook
and buy them a plane ticket to come
visit me and like befriend them in
person and
then uh and then say like okay well
see you see you again sometime like uh
i wish i was in a situation where i saw
my friends more
more often or more like
more on the computer more on the
computer
and then also in person but um
but i have friends yeah have you
do you have emotions that you struggle
with more
more often than others depression or
anxiety or anger or anything like that
oh um i have trouble expressing myself
emotionally
or getting emotional especially since
especially without having like a place
to stay
like it's hard to like break down on the
bus or whatever like really
really like go like on the like uh
bus but uh
sometimes i'm too much of a show off for
the computer
if that makes sense like
like there's an artificial intelligence
not an artificial not an artificial
intelligence sorry but there's like an
intelligence related to the technology
of the computer and i'm like
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah like
check me out check me out
like hi camera i'm saying hi to you the
camera separately from
saying hi to the photographer and
separately from saying hi everything
like
check me out and i and i don't
and so i'm like expressing something to
the cat like camera and ignoring
the person so whatever kind of emotion
that
is like
there must be a word for this i guess
maybe maybe i have a syndrome that that
i can um
that um that fuco doesn't know about
have you been treated for mental
conditions before
yeah i yeah i love
drugs
[Music]
what are you proudest of in your life
oh uh my um
how good i am at naming things like
titling things
and my favorite memory is is
something with the person who lived
across the street from me when i was
growing up on raymond avenue in la
crescenta
something with this person david
griffith i'm not sure which
part of which part i mean maybe
one time i got to sleep over at his
house and i
was waking up in his house and i was
like disoriented for a minute
where am i oh yeah i'm in that guy's
house oh yeah
yeah wow cool i'm in his house maybe
that
and yeah i'm really good at titling
things um
one of my favorite things that i've done
in
naming things is i have a song called
limelight and it's about
simba and nala from the lion king and
also it's about two phones that got
stolen from me
how you end up homeless
i stopped being it's it's complicated
and kind of boring
they weren't supposed to be charging
rent at all the people who were charging
rent it wasn't their house
i stopped being able to afford it and
was evicted
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life the most
important
lesson i've learned in my life is
the the the zodiac like the sign like
like gemini uh cancer lee uh
is real actually for a long time i
dismissed it as
or not dismissed it exactly but just
didn't care about it
and it's really important
to understanding
people and understanding
animals i guess
the signs are named after animals mostly
understanding sexuality i don't think so
but really important understanding
people
and understanding like right writing or
something
understanding do you ever ask your
parents how you got the name math
oh they didn't name me that um when i
was growing up my name was laura snyder
laura holly snyder
and i changed my name to math in
2001 or 2002 and then in 2013 i made it
legal i went to a courthouse in oakland
and changed
it there and got it on my id and stuff
yeah i saw it on your id
why why did you choose the name math
math tender means the big dipper
sorry why did i choose any math i'm good
with numbers um
i wanted something more androgynous
i i got this i got this idea to have
a dog named math or a cat named math
because it
because it's such a cool idea to have a
pet named
math like there's math it's an
interesting name there's math running
around
in your kitchen or whatever like math
math wants something
and i thought about it for a little
while and decided
yeah i want it as my own name even
though it's cooler if it's a cat or a
dog's name
i like it as my own name and i don't
really have pets so
your androgyny is something that you
play up
oh sorry
i'll try not to do that
so your androgyny is something that you
play up
uh i
i'm having trouble thinking of the
reference but
but but i love david bowie that
that's a quote from a boeing interview
right or
i'm just asking you a question my
androgyny is something that i play
up or cultivate cultivate
um comes to you naturally me i don't
think about it that much
my pronoun is he but whatever and uh oh
sorry my pronoun is he but
it's not a big deal i swear and uh
androgyny is something i play up
well i don't want to
i don't want to get defensive i assume
you're letting me know that
it is something i play up even though it
isn't something i
thought i played up well you have a
beard and sideburns and
yo yeah i do take testosterone it's been
a while since i had since i um had a
fresh um
vial but i oh i see what you mean um
uh yes
okay it was we got an answer yeah i um i
take uh like testosterone
yeah and uh do you do you prefer being
would you prefer to be considered a
male i get a huge thrill out of being
called he
but also i
mean when i met you is unclear whether
you're male or female
yeah i'm not trying to do that but i
don't
want i don't want to think about it that
much
so like how do how someone sees me
it's fine if they see me as a girl of
course it's fine
and i get a huge thrill out of it when
they see me as a guy
and then ever like am i ever really
trying to do something where it's like
it's confusing if i'm a girl or a guy
i guess
anyway i don't mind when people ask
about it
we're all free to be who we should be
who we want to be
right yeah yeah yeah sometimes i say
that being a girl is the worst thing i
can think of
and i'm exaggerating like it's not well
it is the worst thing i can think of for
some reason or that i want to it's the
worst thing i want to think about
i don't want to think about like murder
or you think being
a being a woman is well i'm sort of
joking i mean like if you're
if you're a girl and you're a girl and
you like being a girl then
um the then i don't have any idea what
that's like
but uh yeah being a girl
i say like all the time like sort of as
a joke like oh being a girl is the worst
thing i can think of it's not the worst
thing i can think of but it's the worst
thing i can comfortably think about
are you happy would you describe
yourself as happy
i'm in a good mood almost all the time
but i'm kind of uh
i'm kind of miserable i need a computer
and a phone and a place to live
but i'll have them soon i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm in a pretty good mood almost
all the time
and always
always happen
like i don't i don't get depressed
hardly ever
so it's a good thing yeah so like
you know only like comparatively like
that like depressed compared to how i
was
last year or whatever but compared to
people actually um
have like depressions i don't really
i don't really get those i have um
like um
extremely good mental health or i have a
syndrome that hasn't been named yet that
has to do with trying to
impress the
cartoon or whatever more than i
try to connect with a person
okay all right matt thank you very much
for talking with me and uh i wish you
best of luck out there be careful
uh yeah streets are dangerous
yeah i know what you mean
all right thank you very much you're
welcome
you're interesting thank you
you